buongiorno a tutti come state
vi sentite a vostro agio visto che
stiamo parlando di sicurezza
voi vi sentite sicuri sapete
in realtà ci sono alcuni motivi per
preoccuparsi
guardate queste sono le dieci sfide
globali indicate dall'organizzazione
mondiale della sanità come le più
significative tra queste abbiamo
inquinamento povertà malattie non
trasmissibili come cancro diabete che
ben conosciamo
qualcuna di queste però può risultare
una sorpresa per la maggior parte di noi
sei su dieci sono infatti legate a
infezioni da parte di virus e batteri e
agli effetti che questi microrganismi
anno sulla popolazione
abbiamo hev influenza virus ebola virus
dengue la comparsa di microrganismi
sempre più resistenti ai nostri farmaci
e perché no possiamo aggiungere anche
l'esitazione che spesso abbiamo nel
proteggerci
ad esempio quando mettiamo in
discussione la protezione dei vaccini
insomma dobbiamo preoccuparci di queste
minacce
beh la bella notizia è che il nostro
corpo è costruito benissimo abbiamo un
sistema immunitario incredibile noi ci
facciamo caso solo le poche volte in cui
ci ammaliamo ma in realtà in ogni
momento la sicurezza del nostro
organismo è mantenuta da
sofisticatissimi meccanismi di difesa
disposti su più livelli
è davvero incredibile credetemi pensate
che anche le nostre lacrime contengono
un enzima in grado di uccidere batteri
pensate proprio quando ci sentiamo più
deboli in realtà siamo protetti ancor di
più
questo perché abbiamo vissuto
adattandosi alle minacce portate dai
microrganismi
pensate un po a una sorta di guerra
fredda con i microbi un equilibrio di
non belligeranza pensate anche a quei
film di alieni extraterrestri che
arrivano distruggono tutto e l'uomo
all'inizio non può fare altro che
rimanere a guardarle indifeso perché non
conosce le loro armi alla fine di solito
qualcuno trova il modo di sconfiggere
gli alieni e ritorna la pace
ecco questo è quello che accade quando
un virus infetta la specie umana per la
prima volta magari questo virus convive
pacificamente con altri animali che si
sono adattati a lui però quando passa
nell'uomo succede la catastrofe
volete un esempio il virus ebola e vola
convive con i pipistrelli senza causare
loro alcun danno però quando passa
nell'uomo si rompe l'equilibrio è come
l'alieno che arriva su un pianeta che
non conosce e gli effetti sono
devastanti e anche quello che è successo
500 anni fa alle popolazioni indigene
americane l'uomo occidentale gli ha
portato microbi a cui il loro organismo
non era adattato e il vaiolo e il
morbillo hanno devastato queste
popolazioni
molto più dei conquistadores adesso
probabilmente mi direte
vabbè sono cose lontane sono passate
anche bola tutto sommato qui non abbiamo
pipistrelli infettati da ebola ne siamo
sicuri vero ma siamo davvero sicuri in
realtà sappiamo che non potremo mai
escludere la comparsa di una nuova
minaccia microbi
logica l'aveva detto anche il premio
nobel joshua leather berg la più grande
minaccia alla sopravvivenza della specie
umana sono i virus
pensate alla pandemia di hiv
pensate a quando scoppia una nuova
pandemia di influenza
noi non possiamo prevedere quando questi
eventi accadano
però quando questi virus sono comparsi
si sono diffusi ovunque nel mondo anche
qui finora però stiamo parlando di
eventi naturali grazie è arrivata una
lettera
scusate che cosa polvere bene polvere
bianca che strano vabbè lasciamo l'acqua
per il momento e riprendiamo da dove ero
rimasta dicevo le infezioni naturali
possono essere di ispirazione per
malintenzionati e possono essere causate
intenzionalmente per interessi subdoli
aspettate un attimo la polvere bianca mi
ricorda spore di bacillo dell'antrace
dio spero di no non penso di avere
nemici così malevoli a proposito del
bacillo dell'antrace si tratta di un
batterio che troviamo comunemente negli
animali e resiste incredibilmente a
lungo nell'ambiente lo possiamo trovare
nel suolo anche dopo 40 anni grazie alla
sua capacità di formare spore
normalmente questo batterio non è un
problema per l'uomo perché per avere
un'infezione dobbiamo venire in contatto
con una quantità molto più elevata di
quella che solitamente troviamo nel
terreno
tuttavia il contatto accidentale con una
dose artificialmente elevata ha effetti
catastrofici
pensate che se su una città passasse un
aereo e rilasciasse
50 kg disporre di bacillus anthracis in
due giorni circa un quinto delle persone
morirebbero e un altro quarto avrebbero
effetti e lungo termine
in sostanza la metà delle persone in
città non ne uscirebbe indenne ma senza
pensare troppo in grande portando un
esempio concreto nel 2001 dopo l'attacco
alle torri gemelle diverse lettere
contenenti spore di bacillus anthracis e
non farina come questa
furono inviate a sedi di giornali e
uffici amministrativi cinque persone
morirono a causa delle spore inalata
l'apertura della busta anche se queste
quell'attacco non aveva la pretesa di
uccidere su vasta scala
gli effetti economici e sociali furono
notevoli infatti per diverso tempo dopo
quell'evento il panico rimase nella
popolazione con un proliferare di vasto
di falsi allarmi un incremento delle
ospedalizzazioni la chiusura di interi
settori dell'amministrazione pubblica
senza contare la spesa di centinaia di
milioni di dollari per la
decontaminazione delle strutture e
l'installazione di sistemi di
sorveglianza
oggi sappiamo coltivare i batteri
sappiamo produrre manipolare e tossine
agenti patogeni e lo sappiamo fare ha un
costo relativamente basso
pensate che per produrre esporre di
bacillus anthracis con un po di
competenza microbiologica bastano un
garage e qualche apparecchiatura
rudimentale è proprio il basso costo di
produzione a rendere i microbi
un'attrattiva interessante per il loro
utilizzo come arma pensate che in
relazione al danno prodotto il costo di
produzione di un'arma biologica è di 800
volte inferiore a quello di un'arma
nucleare
d'altronde questa convenienza è nota da
molto tempo sin dall'antichità ad
esempio nel 1346 i tartari per
impossessarsi di caffè in crimea
lanciarono cadaveri affetti da peste
all'interno della città in questo modo
la peste si diffuse nella popolazione
debilitando la questa peste verrà poi
accidentalmente trasportata anche in
europa dove diventerà famosa come la
peste nera che decimò la popolazione
europea
oggi però siamo più colti conosciamo di
più e siamo tecnologicamente più
avanzati e allora siamo in grado di
produrre armi biologiche più sofisticate
più potenti e dagli effetti più subdoli
negli anni precedenti alla seconda
guerra mondiale e durante la guerra
fredda erano attivi programmi di
sviluppo in giappone america unione
sovietica per la produzione di armi
microbiologiche basati su batterio della
peste dell'antrace virus ebola e altre
simpatici organismi microrganismi con la
licenza di uccidere
fortunatamente non si ebbe mai uno
scontro su vasta scala con queste armi e
anche oggi le nazioni riconoscono il
pericolo che ne deriverebbe dal loro
utilizzo
tuttavia per parlare di bioterrorismo
non serve pensare a un evento su vasta
scala intere popolazioni che muoiono uso
di virus e batteri letali in guerra
esistono infatti variazioni di questo
tema che potremmo definire più
quotidiane più legate a interessi
politici ad esempio vi racconto un
episodio che è accaduto in america negli
anni 80 in oregon per la precisione
qui si era stabilita una setta religiosa
che aspirava un maggiore potere politico
questa si candidò allora alle elezioni
ma data la loro inferiori
sta numerica per eliminare quanti più
voti contrari possibili causarono
un'epidemia di salmonella diffondendo il
batterio in diversi ristoranti della
capitale
centinaia di persone si ammalarono ma
fortunatamente la setta non vinse le
elezioni neanche in questo modo
insomma che si tratti di infezioni
naturali o che si tratti di attacchi
terroristici
i microrganismi rappresentano un
problema per la nostra sicurezza
dobbiamo quindi preoccuparsene
io penso che sì dobbiamo preoccuparcene
ma senza farci prendere dal panico
sì ce la possiamo fare anche in passato
nel 2003 quando è comparso un nuovo
agente infettivo che causava la sars
i ricercatori sono riusciti in breve
tempo a capire che si trattava di un
nuovo coronavirus e un consenso tra le
nazioni ha permesso il contenimento
dell'infezione in breve tempo quindi ce
la possiamo fare
adesso vorrei spendere un paio di minuti
su un argomento che mi sta
particolarmente a cuore perché quello su
cui lavoro
il virus hiv che causa l'aids ha
provocato milioni di morti per oggi
l'infezione non rappresenta più una
sentenza di morte perché disponiamo di
una combinazione di farmaci che anche se
non elimina il virus almeno lo blocca
però il virus rimane e può comunque
minacciare la nostra sicurezza
tuttavia nonostante lo spauracchio
iniziale causato dall aids il sentimento
comune ignora che il virus è ancora fra
di noi e ad esempio sapete che il 20 30
per cento delle persone infette da hiv 1
sa di esserlo
oltre di aids
abbiamo iniziato a trascurare anche
altre malattie infettive un po con la
stessa superficialità di chi una volta
scampato il pericolo
pensa di essere al sicuro ma così
facendo ci esponiamo il ritorno del nepi
dell'epidemia è inoltre questo
atteggiamento di superficialità è quello
che potrebbe essere sfruttato da chi
vuole minacciare la nostra sicurezza
in fondo se ci pensate
l'attacco bioterroristico è un po come
lo scoppio naturale di un'infezione uno
scoppio improvviso di ebola e le misure
che dovremmo attuare per rispondere e
gestire un'emergenza naturale sono le
stesse che di cui abbiamo bisogno anche
per affrontare un attacco improvviso un
attacco bioterroristico dunque da dove
possiamo trarre conoscenza possiamo
trarre sicurezza secondo me dalla
conoscenza che deriva dalla ricerca
dunque voglio lasciarvi con questo
messaggio
la ricerca è molto importante per
conoscere ciò che ci sta attorno
è importante per crescere per costruire
un futuro più sicuro
perciò non è un optional investiamo su
di essa e avremo un domani più sicuro
grazie per l'attenzione
[Applauso]